[Music]
thank you thank you thank you by the way
my audition for Jersey Shore went quite
well
really ace that thing how you doing Andy
I'm good how are you how does it all
look oh I wish we had time to get a
slow-mo shot of you coming out of the
ocean and just drying my hair I'm not
used to this this is crazy yeah it's
very strange and don't be alarmed about
the color this is the color I get after
about 6 minutes at the beach and then I
burst into flames does the the cornrow
thing hurt yes I've heard looks like it
hurt
it really hurts I thought we were gonna
do a wig and then I came into the know
you said you were gonna get cornrows I
don't know why I let an old prospector
run the show
and they really hurt yeah I bet I don't
know how people do this like a hundred
tiny hands pulling your hair all day
long
all the time as I said the cornrows are
real the cornrows up here took an hour
the ones down below took too
[Applause]
a lot of work went into this and put a
little music behind it let's make it
look pretty
[Music]
[Applause]
disgusting this the starting center for
the oompa-loompa basketball team sheesh
just before we went out I looked in the
mirror and I realized I look like the
predator with hepatitis now a happy
happy to do this it's free it's for a
good cause
but you have to understand I committed
to doing this on this particular date
quite a while ago and the only problem
is that today is also the day I'm
scheduled to take the photo from my
family Christmas card
yeah and I've tried to move it and if we
tog refer couldn't so we went ahead and
took it wasn't my card this year
[Applause]
they'll never get used to this fantastic
anyway beef jerky
you know when I agreed to get the spray
tan I was I had one concern I was
concerned what if it comes out a little
too dark that could be misconstrued I
obviously don't want to offend anybody
so I've asked one of our writers Deon
Cole to inspect my tan and give me his
honest assessment one Indian and tell me
what do you what do you think it's not
racist it's just stupid
[Applause]
that's just stupid gays and gentlemen
what a relief what's that in here dears
you say something bad oh you are gonna
put out one of your own eyes thank you
no no I may not come across right now
but I took my look tonight very
seriously I wanted to do this the right
way okay so before I underwent this and
by the way I should point out some
people probably think I just got the
face and the hands done I went all the
way ladies and gentlemen and just to
prove it to you I had them leave a patch
so you can see my actual
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean I did the whole thing and it
looks good